ah c'est la soie du handicace d'armée ça
va pas être des images digne d'une série
télé policière celle de la spectaculaire
est resté à Sion de celui que la SQ
considère comme le membre en règle plus
influent de tous les Angels au Canada
Martin Robert l'impressionnante
opération policière a eu lieu vers 10h10
ce matin sur l'autoroute 50 à la hauteur
de Granville sur la rouge au même moment
des dizaines de policiers de la SQ
frappaient à 8 endroits à Laval et dans
les Basses Laurentides en plus du
domicile de Martin Robert ceux de ses
présumés lieutenant Stéphane plouf et
Michel la montagne ainsi que leur
partenaire d'affaires le mafieux
Francesco del balzo ont été visés par
des perquisitions
2021 vous l'avez mentionné ça mobilise
quand même 70 policiers c'est les squat
national de répression du crime organisé
et c'est perquisition là elles sont à
collaboration non seulement avec la
Sûreté du Québec le SPVM le Service de
police de Laval de Blainville ainsi que
de mirabelles c'est donc la taille de
l'organisation des Hells qui est visée
par cette vaste opération Talence un
message ça peut
déstabiliser pendant peut-être quelques
jours ou quelques semaines certains
réseaux mais tout va dépendre s'ils sont
incarcérées réellement et puis pendant
combien de temps ils vont être
incarcérés donc c'est très symbolique
mais il faut le faire selon nos sources
policières Francesco del balzo a
également reçu la visite des enquêteurs
il y a quelques jours en lien avec la
tentative de meurtre contre Léonardo
risutto au terme de l'interrogatoire ce
dernier a dû remettre son passeport
l'arrestation on la relâché aussi de
Monsieur del Balso elle est par contre
c'est en soi intéressante parce que on
voit que les policiers essayent un petit
peu de calmer le jeu donc si Monsieur
delbaso essayait de de quitter pour
l'Italie c'est pas pour rien donc on
peut se on peut supposer que il sentait
un peu la soupe chaude ici au Québec
aucune mise en accusation on était prévu
aujourd'hui dans cette phase de
l'enquête criminelle ici Pascal Robida
Radio-Canada à Sainte-Sophie dans les
bases Laurentides